last night the men told all and as you'd
expect
they waited patiently for their turns to
talk
to me
just kidding it was a mess it's time for
roses and rose joining us now is the man
who
left tasha crying on the side of the
road
blake moynes so what went through your
mind when you
watched those tears it's tough to watch
it back but it in a way kind of made me
realize
the connection that we had was there and
it wasn't uh it wasn't fabricated in any
way
do you think more time would have made a
difference with you and taysha i do
i feel like deep down she probably felt
that too and that's maybe why she got
emotional like she did
what was your favorite meme about you
brony cleaning products
that one for sure sully that lion from
that uh madagascar movie
blake thanks so much for joining us and
now we are joined by the man who went
toe to toe with harvard's finest
noah herb how did it feel to get in the
last word
with bennett i personally think you're
an ostentatious
harvard i did go to sleep kind of
chuckling and smiling and happy about it
because i finally got to
say my piece on instagram last night he
compared himself side by side to
carrie grant do you know who cary grant
is you can age me i had to look him up
he's not cary grant we saw you
kind of chug some tic tacs at one moment
are you getting a tic tac
sponsorship or yeah i don't know if
tic-tac wants me after that
do you plan on growing back that
beautiful mustache and giving it to us
again i let the mustache decide
if he's feeling like he's ready to come
back out we'll see we'll see how it goes
down
thanks noah good luck growing back that
[Music]
mustache